la comisión europea quiere poner fin a
la rigidez de las reglas Fiscales que se
habían aplicado hasta la pandemia porque
consideran que están alejadas de la
realidad actual aseguran desde la
comisión europea Bruselas ha propuesto
unas medidas mucho más realistas En qué
se deberá reducir la deuda pública de
los países disparada desde la pandemia
pero para poder reducir esta deuda
pública se hará de forma mucho más
gradual mucho más paulatina y realista
lo que ayudará a países muy endeudados
como Italia España o Francia a que
tendrán que sanear sus cuentas públicas
pero a un ritmo mucho más realista que
no implique automáticamente una
austeridad ni unos recortes masivos que
les llevaría a una posible recepción en
todo caso las normas principales sí que
se mantendrán es decir no podrá haber
más de un 3% del déficit ni tampoco más
de un 60% de deuda público pero para
llegar a estas cifras no se aplicará
unos recortes masivos cada año como si
se habían aplicado en el pasado cada
país tendrá que presentar unos planes
nacionales a los que la comisión europea
tendrá que dar su visto bueno si hay
desvíos los países se podrán enfrentar a
multas algo que también se contempla
ahora pero hasta ahora las multas eran
excesivas y nunca se habían llegado a
aplicar Bruselas ha caído en la
evidencia que si hay recortes no
inversión y sin inversión por lo tanto
la economía europea no puede ser
competitiva ante gigantes como Estados
Unidos o china ahora los países tendrán
que dar su visto bueno esta nueva
propuesta aunque las discusiones se
prevén muy complicadas especialmente
porque Alemania y ha dicho que esta
propuesta no le gusta que quiere más
mano dura y evitar que los países se
acomoden en exceso